meine these heute abend ist eine
forderung die lautet ich fordere die
politik auf nicht endlich ein für alle
mal in ruhe zu lassen was corona
betrifft nach zwei jahren pandemie bin
ich es leid dass politiker und ernste
meinen sie könnten sich besser um meine
gesundheit kümmern als ich selbst er ist
heute der vorsitzendes welt
ärzteverbandes frank ulrich montgomery
zur vorsicht ein ostern gewarnt maske
tragen abstand halten genauso wie die
letzten zwei jahre als hätten wir es
nicht schon tausend mal gehört auch
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach
jetzt zur maske test abstand und das
obwohl deutschland in statistik nicht
sonderlich gut abschneidet in schweden
ist die lebenserwartung gegenüber
2009/10 jahr gestiegen während
deutschland mehr als vier monate
verloren hat auf welcher grundlage also
meint die politik und bürgern weiter in
kronau ratschläge zu erteilen
ich möchte es einmal ganz hart
ausdrücken mir reicht ist und ich bin ab
jetzt auch raus ich habe keine lust mehr
die von der politik etwas vorschreiben
zu lassen
wie geht das ganz ähnlich also große
sympathie es war aber von vornherein
klar dass die politik also von diesen
neuen spielsachen die sie dabei kommen
hat nicht so gerne so schnell wieder
würde lassen wollen wenn ich also dass
das gängige dass vorschriften machen
dass da hat man sich in zwei jahren
unheimlich schnell daran gewöhnt ich
würde jetzt bei henry sagen es ist
vielleicht nicht die avantgarde der
ärzteschaft die sich geäußert und es hat
ja durchaus auch ärzte und
verbandsvertreter aus dem bereich
gegeben die ihn auch während der ganzen
phase öfter mal zu mäßigung aufgerufen
haben insofern bin ich so ein bisschen
hoffnungsvoll wenn man durch die stadt
geht da hilft sicher jetzt auch das
schöne frühlingswetter dann sieht man
doch dass an stellen wo es nicht so
dramatisch lebensgefährlich ist zum
beispiel auf einem wenig besuchten
wochen mag die leute jetzt doch wieder
mit mehr mit offenem gesicht rumlaufen
auf dem wochenmarkt haben sie völlig
recht habe ich das schon vor wochen
beobachtet wo kann es gar nicht fassen
das sind fast alle leute ohne maske
rumgelaufen ich habe mich wahnsinnig
frei gefühlt es ist ja in einigen
gegenden von deutschland noch finster
also erstaunlicherweise im liberalen
hamburg das gilt ja noch als hotspot da
ist ja sehr viel verboten das sind noch
die ganz alten zuständig kann es gar
nicht glauben liberale hamburg und in
mecklenburg vorpommern fangen die jetzt
langsam an zu lockern weil die
ministerpräsidentin so als handlangerin
putins in verschiss geraten ist will
sich irgendetwas in politisches machen
muss die fangen langsam an zu lockern
ansonsten liebe lena gebe ich dir
vollkommen recht man muss sich einfach
selbst befreien das ist übrigens immer
richtig selbstbefreiung also ich weiß
nicht ob sie den schönen satz kennen von
ronald reagan der hat mal gesagt die
zwölf furchterregendsten worte in der
englischen sprache sind ich komme hier
von der regierung dir zu helfen
da hat er schon delicti gerechter mit
und ich sag mal so die these es gibt
auch ein menschenrecht eigentlich in
ruhe gelassen zu werden der bund ist
jetzt gar nicht nur auf corona sondern
ganz prinzipiell als ich sagt
menschenrecht in ruhe gelassen zu werden
ganz allgemein
ja ich finde ja eine erinnerung daran
wenn man jetzt zu ostern mit seiner
familie zusammen kommt also in
vielleicht oma und opa dabei dann
nochmal zu erinnern ja wohl vielleicht
vorher testen das kann man ja machen
aber wir sind doch keine unmündigen
kinder wir haben doch auch die
nachrichten verfolgt ja wir machen sie
da wurde ja sogar als journalisten sind
daran dass wissen doch die menschen
mittlerweile es braucht doch nicht immer
jahren lass dich testen maske auf diese
ermahnungen man kann doch selbst
entscheiden wie man sich verhält die
leute sind nicht doof und ich möchte
auch von da stimme ich gefährlich zum
politiker nicht so als ungültig machen
aber es gab ja von anfang an ein
unglaublich bevormundenden ton absolute
in der in der ganzen kampagne auch fürs
handy ich hatte auch nie lust mir von
jens spahn erklären zu lassen wie man
sich die hände da wurde und beim
händewaschen happy birthday singen
gemacht damit wir wissen dass solche
absurden
meine disziplin ist unsere beste medizin
also da hatte man ja das geschieht wenn
ihr gleich in zehn pionier gebote auf
gesagt also es hat schon was erfolgs
erzählerische war die ursula von der
leyen können sich daran erinnern wie hat
sich die hände gewaschen und dazu die
europahymne gesummt und müssen als video
gepostet hat das jemand gesehen an dem
anfang ja also das war
und das war ihr bester beitrag
wahrscheinlich gab ihnen einen
erstaunlichen satz von karl lauterbach
also heute ist ja diskutiert worden über
den das ist eine geplante entführung
durch eine rechtsradikale internetgruppe
eine jet gruppe und übrigen sachen die
man ernst nehmen soll man soll sich da
nicht drüber erheben denn
auch wenn man die leute für spinner hält
ein einzeltäter der zur waffe greift
findet sich schnell also können uns ja
auch an herrn kupka erinnern der in
hessen von einem einzeltäter erschossen
worden es geht ganz schnell da muss man
sehr ernst nehmen auch wenn die als
komplette spieler auftreten er sagte
jedenfalls in seiner stellungnahme dazu
er sehe jetzt auch wie tief gespalten
die gesellschaft sei und er wolle etwas
dazu tun die wieder zusammenzubringen
dann so was hat er glaube ich überhaupt
noch nie gesagt sondern hat immer weiter
zugespitzt und holz gehackt und jetzt
legt da vielleicht mal die axt weg und
wird ein bisschen wie soll ich sagen
versöhnlich schauen hat zwar hoffe ich
jedenfalls aber dann hat er wieder
seinen ganzen wert eigentlich verloren
ich meine kalt aber braucht coruna ja
mit dem punkte steht das immer noch
einen sagen es ist ganz schlimm dass man
ihren führen wollten also ich habe ja
auch hier keiner hatte war es oft genau
dann sind natürlich der zweigstellen
jemand haben also
ich glaube dass der mann als die
politische wirkung angeht jetzt vom fast
rücktritt der war ja erledigt kann ja er
hat ja die die impfpflicht nicht
durchgesetzt hat er nichts erreicht und
ist eigentlich schon nach wenigen
monaten gescheitert im amt und
eigentlich wäre reif für eine
auswechslung aber jetzt ist natürlich
durch diese geplante entführung ist er
irgendwie zur irgendwie wieder zur
kultfigur geworden und nicht anfassbar
also falls scholz mal darüber
nachgedacht hat ihn ausgewechselt das
tut er jetzt bestimmt nicht mehr also
karl lauterbach ist sicher wir werden im
herbst noch erleben wenn was immer dann
da los ist kommt er wieder aus der kiste
aber herr joop als analytisch machte er
die legislaturperiode voll also wird er
in vier jahren noch im amt sein wenn man
das weiß ich nicht danke gebe ich ja
keiner prognose habe ich wünsche es mir
nicht ich wünsche mir eine exakte ist
der posten wo ich für eine frau wünsche
die was vom fach versteht und nicht
einen so offensichtlich durch die
eigenen furien der eigenen seele
gehetzten man es ist ja auch so dass in
der spd fraktion sich glaube ich also
niemand vorher so richtig vorstellen
konnte dass also ein lauter bekleidet da
war man auch erstaunt und wollte ihn ja
offensichtlich auch nicht im kabinett
haben also das ist ja der eine
kandidatin wirklich rein gedrückt worden
ist und jetzt muss er damit leben also
ich habe jetzt nicht so starke emotionen
gegen lauterbach gehabt wie viele andere
aber was ist nicht verstehe jetzt
vertritt der politik teilweise gegen
seine eigenen überzeugungen ja und das
finde ich das passt im grunde genommen
nicht so ganz zu ja das jahr zeigte aber
ein ich hätte zurücktreten ist ja er
zeigt ja war gegen die lockerung der der
das immer so des
gesundheitsschutzgesetzes wer weiter
gegen was die fdp durchgesetzt hat aber
hat es trotzdem vertreten das hat er in
einem atemzug ja mal wieder vorgetragen
da waren natürlich wirklich ruiniert
dadurch das kann man nicht machen und er
hat sich als selbst korrigiert also
ergibt eine entscheidung an einem tag
bekannt dann zu haben der talkshow bei
lanz und nehmen die entscheidung zurück
solche sachen das ist halt nicht machbar
aber nun ist er erstmal fest im sattel
wir werden noch eine zeit lang ertragen
müssen lena wird ja immer noch
ratschläge erhalten bleiben da ich
glaube ja schon dass man darüber reden
muss auch ich habe eben diese statistik
angesprochen was mir ganz große angst es
geht ja gerade auf twitter zum beispiel
dieser aktion ich habe mitgemacht man
herrscht ein es ist eine initiative die
aufgeschrieben hat wer was gesagt hat ob
journalisten politiker ich muss sagen
mit der seite wie sie aufgemacht ist
sind die sehe ich nicht aber mit der
aktion an sich mal zusammen die
ungeimpfte behandelt wurde im winter das
halte ich für sehr sehr sinnvoll und da
ist auch noch mal meine frage an sie
frau das gebiet sich das denn entwickeln
also müssen wir nicht dass auch
aufarbeiten was passiert ist vor allem
wenn jetzt statistiken zeigen also so
doll war der deutschen weg doch nicht ja
also ich halte das für dringend
notwendig und es ist natürlich jetzt
eine schwierige politische situation da
wir ja nun sehr sehr beschäftigt sind
sehr zu recht mit dem sehr viel größeren
schrecklicheren probleme und keine krise
gerät das so ein bisschen ins
hintertreffen ich glaube wir brauchen
dringend eine aufarbeitung ich bin sehr
für eine enquete kommission die sich
nochmal ganz systematisch damit befasst
ist auch vor dem hintergrund der
entsetzlichen bilder die wir aus
shanghai sehen ja doch noch einmal sehr
deutlich vor augen geführt wird dass
eine demokratische lösung einer in der
weise abgeschlossene gesellschaft nicht
sein kann natürlich war es hier nie so
schlimm aber die tendenzen waren doch
schon sehr übergriffig ging sehr
großzügig mit den grundrechten um und
man ist jetzt bereit das so ein bisschen
mit erleichterung unter den teppich zu
kehren das darf meiner meinung nach
nicht geschehen ist ist auch wichtig zu
dokumentieren wer hat wer hat was gesagt
wo stehen wir denn tatsächlich bei den
sterberaten anja im vergleich zu anderen
ländern also und welche maßnahmen haben
denn überhaupt was gebracht die haben
sich ja hartnäckig geweigert also
sozusagen irgendwie zu evaluieren welche
maßnahme eigentlich was genau bewirkt wo
sich leute anstecken wer sich genau an
steckt ich habe neulich jetzt von einem
statistischen instituts teil gelesen
dass also sagen die die wenigen toten
dass sie die 200 menschen tatsächlich
noch täglich gezählt werden die an
hunger sterben das sind nicht das sind
schüler natürlich sterben ja nicht
alkohol und jetzt schon mit corona
sterben die sind aber im schnitt jetzt
älter als das durchschnittsalter vor der
pandemie insgesamt war ich muss mal muss
man sich irgendwie verhalten zur zur
ehre dieser redaktion sagen es kann eine
junge frau aus dieser redaktion die über
dieses neue diese neue plattform
geschrieben hat und die für mich erst
bekannt gemacht hat und das ist eine
großartige journalistische leistung
fällt es einem nicht so einfach sich
damit durchzusetzen mit seiner
geschichte aber das hat sie getan und
das muss ich einfach mal sagen gute
redaktion ja wir haben bei vier nach
ganz tolle redakteurinnen die sich immer
dafür 1 in dem fall war sehr wertig
achterberg ist wirklich großartig aber
wie würden sie das denn sagen herr
doktor doktor zillmann wie kann man
verhindern dass in der zukunft so etwas
noch mal passiert oder wie kann man es
jetzt auch dokumentiert ich meine essen
ganze familien daran zerbrochen dass die
menschen in ungeimpft und gebens
unterschieden haben da gab es zehn die
waren ja furchtbar
also für mich ist das eigentlich
interessante an der ganzen geschichte
dass wir hier ein gigantisches staats
und politik versagen gehabt haben und
zwar leider halt nicht nur diesem
bereich am anfang des endes haben völlig
von der anfang sein also hat man nichts
funktioniert man spricht immer vom von
marktversagen ja aber hier ist es
politik versagen als das absurdeste war
ja da macht man so fälschungssichere
gutscheine die man der apotheke dann
einlösen kann gegen die maske ist aber
bis heute nicht der lage eine
fälschungssichere impfausweis zu machen
ja und ich meine wir könnten alle endlos
sachen aufzählen und man sieht sie aber
überall ja wenn man sieht die bundeswehr
ist mehr oder minder schrotthaufen heute
digitalisierung fehlanzeige ja und wo
man hinguckt sehe ich eigentlich überall
staatsversagen technisch ist also
anhänger immer so auf dass die leute
ständig von marktversagen reden ich sagt
reden wenn man vom staatsversagen das
ist noch größer als das marktversagen
nicht auf ihrer seite das fing ja damit
an dass herr wiler der chef des rk ii
ganz zum anfang gesagt hat die maske
taugt nix sie brauchen wir noch gar
nicht genau so wie hat das los ja jetzt
ist einer der großmufti ist das masken
der des maskenballs soll ein durfte mein
tücher benutzen ja auch einen zeit
lernen und alles was man benutzt muss
aber dieses jahr war sie natürlich auch
sagen sagen ich will die politik den
schutz nehmen aber viele menschen sind
auch begeistert mit gelaufen also mit
den zustimmungs zahlen zu der rigiden
politik in der regierung am anfang waren
bei 80 prozent das muss man sich mal
vorstellen und wir waren immer ein
kleiner relativ versprengter haufen der
gesagt hat halo aber das grundrecht aus
und das bilderhaus
auch eine freiheitlich orientierte frau
das hat mich an diesem volk negativ
überrascht das hätte ich nicht für
möglich gehalten die staatsgläubig die
mehrheit der neue jahr so viel und
welche einschränkungen ihrer freiheit
sie klaglos hinnehmen über lange zeit
dass es ist vieles wieder denkbar für
mich geworden